This is a Wendover Productions video made
possible by Backblaze and in
collaboration with Alternate History Hub and
Real Life Lore.
Russia is immense--it spans 5,000 miles across,
2,000 miles vertically12, crosses 11 time
zones3, borders everywhere from Norway to
North Korea4, and is as close to Anchorage
as it is
to Amsterdam5.
It’s huge... but it has a problem.
A problem that can explain part of why the
average Russian, living at the same latitude
as Finland, Sweden, Norway, Iceland, and Canada,
makes only $7,500 American dollars per year.
A problem that can explain at least a portion
of
almost every political decision the country
has ever made.
Russia’s geography is flawed.
What you have to remember about Russia is
that the majority of Russians live in Europe.
3/4 of Russia’s population lives in the
western quarter of the country6.
Therefore, as a country
with a fairly centralized power system, many
of its decisions go to protect the country
core in
and around Moscow.
You see, a lot of the success of certain countries
over others depends on how well its
geography protects it.
The US, for example, benefited hugely from
being an ocean away from
every large military power.
The only real armed forces that could threaten
the US in its infancy
were in Europe and Asia and therefore any
invasion would require trans-oceanic supply
lines
which are hugely expensive and logistically
difficult therefore weakening an invading
army.
On
the European continent, France has a similar
situation—their northwestern border is protected
by
the English channel, their western border
by the Atlantic Ocean, their southern border
by the
Pyrenees mountains and Mediterranean ocean,
their southeastern by the Alps mountains,
and
their northeastern by the Rhine river7.
The eastern half of their northern border
is, however,
largely unprotected geographically—a flaw
Germany exploited in both World War One and
World War Two by invading through Belgium
and Luxembourg—but the protection still
did
concentrate attacks into a choke point and
kept the country significantly more protected
than
other European countries.
Here’s Cody from Alternate History Hub to
explain Russia’s territorial expansion.
Russia’s first territorial expansion since
it first became a unified East Slavic State
in 8828 was
entirely a quest for power.
But over time this growth for glory transformed
into an effort to
protect the very core of the country.
This early Russia was at very unprotected
and vunerable.
There was no geographic protection to keep
foreigners from migrating into their lands.
The only
natural resource Russia had their disposal
to repel an invader was pure manpower.
In the coming
centuries, what was then known as the Grand
Duchy of Moscow quickly expanded.
By the time
Ivan the Terrible was crowned ruler of the
Tsardom of Russia, the country had spread
it’s borders
east to the Urals, south to the Caucasus mountains,
and west to the Carpathians.
Soon even
Siberia was conquered which before then, was
an independent Khanate—a territory ruled
by a
Khan.
That was Cody from Alternate History Hub.
I collaborated with him to make a great
video on his channel about what the world
would be like if Russia had never become its
own country which I’ll link in the description
and at the end of the video.
Now, with all this territory, Russia, or at
least Moscow, had some serious protection9.
Siberia is large enough that no army could
invade through it and make it to Moscow.
The supply
lines would have to be thousands of miles
long through inhospitable conditions.
Not only that,
but that army with a one or two thousand mile
long supply line would then have to make it
over
the Ural mountains to get to Moscow10.
Attacking from the south or west would also
take an
army either across water or through mountains.
By the time the 19th century rolled in, Russia
had truly become an unconquerable power.
Countries could and can take over portions
of Russia,
but there is no conceivable way that a single
country could fully occupy and conquer Russia.
To
occupy a territory of that size, a country
would need an estimated 13 million trained
ground
troops--more than the 17 largest militaries
combined11.
However, despite its defenses, Russia has
never developed economically to the same level
as some of its neighbors.
Its GDP per capita is
right around that of Mauritius, Grenada, and
Turkey12.
And this, once again, can be at least
partially attributed to Geography.
Historically, naval power equaled power.
The two were synonymous.
There was no better
way for countries to project their power and
grow their economy than to have a powerful
navy
and merchant fleet.
Many of the most powerful countries today--the
United Kingdom, Japan, and
China for example--were ones that once had
the most powerful navies in the world.
There’s a
reason that none of the 18 largest economies
in the world are landlocked countries13.
Up until the
last century, maritime shipping was the fastest
way to get goods and people across the world
and
its still cheapest way to ship goods long
distance.
Having good water access allows countries
to
trade with the world but Russia, despite its
23 thousand miles of coastline14, has no significant
warm-water, ice-free ports with direct access
to an ocean.
Alaska does, Canada does, Iceland
does, Norway does, and Sweden too, but Russia
is fundamentally limited in its maritime power
because it has no easy way to access the world’s
oceans year round.
The port of Novorossiysk is
ice-free, but its throughput is limited both
by the depth and size of the port15.
St Petersburg also
has an important port, but it freezes for
many months of the year.
On the Pacific side, ports like
Vladivostok also occasionally freeze during
the winter.
But the ice is not the biggest problem
with these ports.
The biggest problem is that their access to
the worlds oceans is all through
choke-points controlled by either NATO countries
or NATO allies.
To get to the ocean from
Novorossiysk, you need to pass through the
Bosphorus straight which is controlled by
Turkey—a
NATO country; to get to the ocean from St
Petersburg you need to pass through the Danish
straights controlled by Denmark—also a NATO
country16; and to get to the ocean from
Vladivostok and many of the other Pacific
ports you need to pass through the sea of
Japan which
is controlled by Japan—a close ally of NATO.
If Russia ever decided to attack a NATO country,
their access to the oceans would be restricted
by these NATO countries17 because the NATO
treaty includes a mutual defense pact—if
one country is attacked, all respond.
This would cripple
both Russia's navy and economy.
Now, back to defenses.
There’s one major flaw to Russia’s geographical
defense system--
the northern European plain.
Whereas every other border has a geographical
defense preventing
easy invasion from a foreign army, this completely
flat plain just acts as a funnel easily bringing
an army from Western Europe right up to Moscow
. While 18 a large part of the Soviet Union’s
motive to expand into eastern Europe was to
spread the socialist revolution, Stalin still
believed
that he needed to create a zone of buffer
states in order to defend against the threat
of the USA
and its allies in Western Europe19.
With its influence over all of Eastern Europe,
the USSR had
both manpower and political power to keep
the west far from Moscow.
Since the fall of the
Soviet Union, Russia has continued to strive
to keep political power in the region.
Out of the 15
states that emerged from the Soviet Union,
12 joined a Commonwealth of Independent States
with Russia20--essentially aligning them politically
with Russia--while three joined both NATO
and the European Union--Lithuania, Latvia,
and Estonia.
That means that, on paper, Russia still
had a strong political buffer between it and
western Europe.
The Russian exclave of Kaliningrad,
and the countries of Belarus and Ukraine covered
almost all of the Northern European Plain.
Not only that, but Russia used its influence
in Ukraine to sign a long term lease on the
warmwater
port of Sevastopol which greatly expanded
the naval capabilities of Russia’s black-sea
fleet21.
Except, Ukraine as a whole progressed to be
more and more pro-European in the decades
following the fall of the Soviet Union which
was a major reason for Russia’s invasion
of Crimea.
While on the surface Putin might have claimed
Russia’s invasion was to save the Russians
of the
area from the increasingly westernizing country,
the annexation of Crimea was in reality a
strategic imperative to keep warm-water port
of Sevastopol.
A Ukraine that was friendlier to the
west likely would have ended Russia’s lease
on the port so in Putin’s mind, he needed
to invade
Crimea in order to prevent a crippling blow
to Russia’s ocean access.
Now, Russia has managed to overcome many of
its geographic challenges partially
because of two things--oil and natural gas.
It has enormous energy reserves partially
because of
its enormous size.
Russian natural gas pipelines provide for
40% of Europe’s natural gas
demand.
Some countries such as Bulgaria, Lithuania,
Latvia, Estonia, and Finland are almost
fully dependent on Russia for their natural
gas . This 22 gas dependency is a major reason
why
Germany, for example, a country with high
Russian oil dependency, is much less likely
to
criticize Russia than a country like the UK,
which has virtually zero Russian gas dependency.
If
Russia shut off the gas to Germany, it would
devastate them, but stopping gas exports to
the UK
would have little effect.
The US has attempted to reduce Russian influence
in Europe by
exporting liquefied natural gas across the
Atlantic.
It costs more, but it allows western european
countries to buy their energy from their American
ally.
Now, none of this discussion of ports and
power is to say that if there was no Norway
or
Sweden blocking the way to the ocean and the
water was a bit warmer Russia would be the
Sweden of the East.
Saying that would be foolish.
Geography does have an enormous influence
on human development, but it doesn’t determine
it.
Much of history is defined by chance, not
circumstance because, in the end, reality
is just the confluence of chance and circumstance.
This video was made possible by Backblaze,
so I was going to do this big
complicated pitch where I figure out the value
of computer data in order to calculate the
return on investment for signing up to Backblaze,
but then it was pointed out to me that,
you already know you should back up your data.
It’s like brushing your teeth, doing the
dishes, taking out the trash—its something
that you know you should do but don’t want
to
because its easy to ignore it.
The only thing is, backing up your data doesn’t
have to be
difficult or expensive.
With backblaze, you just download their application
to your
computer, pay $5 per month, and it works in
the background continuously backing up your
data.
You can just completely forget about it.
If you ever do lose your data, all you have
to
do is sign into your account at backblaze.com
and download your data.
If your internet isn’t
fast enough, they even have an option to ship
you a physical drive with your data instead.
Whats best is that you can try this out for
free for 15 days by using the link backblaze.com/
wendover.
If you lose your data during those 15 days,
you’ll still get it back at no cost.
After
that its only $5 per month for the peace of
mind of knowing that, no matter what, your
data
is safe.
By signing up at this link, you’ll also
be helping me out so I can make more great
Wendover Productions videos.
Once again, sign up over at backblaze.com/wendover
to get
a 15 day free trial—thats 15 free days of
knowing your data is safe.
I want to remind you to check out the video
that Alternate History Hub made about
what the world would be like if Russia didn’t
exist.
It’s a great video, and then he
collaborated with Real Life Lore to make another
great video about what would happen if
the Soviet Union Reunited.
Other than that, you can support Wendover
Productions at www.patreon.com/
wendoverproductions, follow me on Twitter
@WendoverPro, watch my last video on The
Economics of Airline Class here, check out
my fan-moderated subreddit here, and most
of
all, subscribe to this channel to receive
all my future videos right when they come
out.
Thanks again for watching, and I’ll see
you in two weeks for another Wendover
Productions video.